en
bonjour à tous je vous propose d'écouter
l'examen du projet de loi sur
l'agriculture l'alimentation et la forêt
un texte adopté par les sénateurs le 24
juillet dernier c'est donc désormais au
député de valider définitivement ce
texte
cette loi se veut une double performance
économique et écologique qui prend le
virage de l'agroécologie avec en
particulier la création de groupements
d'intérêts économiques et
environnementaux c'est une des mesures
phares de ce texte ce gie giec serait un
collectif d'agriculteurs qui désirent
s'engager dans l'agro écologie
la présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
man group a déposé cet amendement vous
devez donc le reconnaître en première
lecture nous souhaitions le soumettre
une nouvelle fois votre attention car
vous l'aurez compris nous y tenons
beaucoup
il s'agit ici le rendre obligatoire
la présence des représentants des
interprofessions au sein des conseils
spécialisés de france agrimer dans le
dispositif actuel des interprofessions
sont simplement consulté faut-il le
rappeler à titre d'expert
l'article 2 renforce le rôle de
l'établissement public une instance qui
est déjà si je puis dire le bras armé de
la politique d'orientation des filières
agricoles vous le savez en effet
franceagrimer exerce des missions
fondamentales que sont au niveau
opérationnel pour l'exécution des
politiques de soutien aux filières
agricoles en matière d'information
économique par la collecte des données
sur les productions ou encore par
l'animation des filières à travers des
conseils spécialisés il serait par
conséquent nous semble-t-il logique
d'intégrer des représentants des
interprofessions au sein des conseils
spécialisés avec le débat sur la
stratégie des filières soient menées
avec tous les acteurs concernés c'est le
sens de cet amendement que je vous
engage bien sûr à soutenir ardemment
merci monsieur le sénateur colin et avec
mes excuses monsieur le rapporteur pour
la commission mais si madame la
présidente monsieur colin nous avons
déjà beaucoup parlé de votre amendement
moi j'ai émis un avis défavorable parce
que les interprofessions sont déjà
représentées au sein des camps s'est
spécialisé dans l'es11 et on pense que
nous pensons que ça pouvait faire
redondance que c'est pas utile donc je
comprends l'intérêt de flécher de
marquer les interprofessions je le
prends comme un amendement d'appel fort
mais je vous demande soit de le retirer
soit vous je serai contraint d'émettre
un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur à vis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre mais
ma vie même argumentation la présidente
je vais donc mettre aux voix cet
amendement numéro il est retiré très
bien merci je mets se voit l'article 2
qui et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
cet article est donc adopté article 3
hrs un amendement numéro 101 présentée
par monsieur l'abbé pour le groupe
écologiste oui madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre chers collègues cet
amendement concerne la méthanisation la
méthanisation agricole doit rester une
activité complémentaire à l'activité
d'agriculteur et non pas devenir le
moteur de projets industriels non
pourvoyeur d'emplois agricoles est
source de dommages sanitaires et
environnementaux c'est pourquoi cet
amendement propose de fixer une limite à
la puissance des réacteurs permettant de
prétendre à la classification
d'activités agricoles cette puissance
maximale est fixée par décret
au-delà de la question de puissance les
méga méthaniseur s'inscrivent dans une
logique d'exploitation industrielle ont
des effets induits néfastes pour
l'environnement la santé et le bien-être
animal dans des élevages de plus en plus
concentrationnaire pollution des nappes
phréatiques par les boues d'épandage
recours intensif aux antibiotiques
ensuite transmis au lait à la viande
dans le cas des vaches en définitive il
s'agit d'établir que l'activité agricole
doit rester une activité liée à la
maîtrise et à l'exploitation d'un cycle
biologique de caractère végétales et
animales et non une activité
industrielle et c'est une part de
réponses aux méga projets comme celui
des millevaches parce qu'on n'a pas la
réponse par là et par la possibilité de
préemption safer et donc c'est une part
de réponse que de limiter la capacité
des méthaniseurs je crois qu'on nous
regarde on nous écoute à ce sujet là et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je le
défend avec force je vous remercie
monsieur le sénateur pour la commission
monsieur le rapporteur votre avis oui
merci mon avis est défavorable parce que
nous ne partageons
nous avons une divergence de fond avec
monsieur avec monsieur l'abbé il le sait
personne ne veut des outrances personne
ne veut partir tous azimuts nafa on peut
aussi considérer que des professionnels
font des usines de méthanisation
respectant l'environnement il n'y a pas
de raison toujours de montrer du doigt
et de dire ça va être une catastrophe
dans le cadre des génies 2e évidemment
nous avons la volonté cet outil qui est
exceptionnel qui va relancer
quelque part le collectif dans
l'agriculture il pourra y avoir des
usines de méthanisation fait à
l'intérieur mais ne faisons pas ça de
façon exclusive après toujours prendre
leur temps tout rompre en référence à
l'allemagne tantôt on critique
l'allemagne c'est pas le sujet ne nous
comparons pas d'autres comparent ont
tout simplement ce que nous faisons nous
voulons une agriculture respectueuse de
l'environnement nous voulons des
activités économiques qui aillent dans
le bon sens la méthanisation et c'est
quelque chose de très important pour
notre pays travaillons surtout monsieur
le ministre monsieur deux fois donné
d'accord à faire en sorte qu'il ne
faille pas un an ou deux ou trois ans
avec tous les recours fait par les uns
et des autres pour mettre en place un
méthaniseur mais qu'on puisse le faire
de façon plus rapide comme cela est le
cas en allemagne d'ailleurs il ne s'agit
pas de vouloir faire toujours plus gros
ne comparons pas lusine débile vaches ou
des 500 vaches à cet amendement je suis
au regret monsieur l'abbé de vous dire
que j'émets un avis défavorable
moi je crois en l'homme je crois en la
conscience collective et je crois en
l'évolution de la mentalité de nos
concitoyens des agriculteurs comme du
monde économique pour aller dans ce sens
et je veux réaffirmer ici en mon nom
personnel mais je pense que nous serons
tous d'accord que la diversification des
sources d'énergie et que la
méthanisation est quelque chose de très
important pour l'avenir de notre pays et
des déchets agricoles notamment merci
monsieur le rapporteur rapide du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre la
présidente évidemment nous sommes tous
ici mobilisés sur les problématiques de
transition énergétique et dans cette
problématique de transition énergétique
nous savons qu'une des données c'est
aussi d'aller vite dans le cadre de
cette transition énergétique aussi
mettre des normes nouvelles ne semblent
pas du tout l'esprit dans lequel nous
devons travailler il peut y avoir des
projets tout à fait intéressant d'abord
pour l'environnement globalement sinon
on avance avec une puissance supérieure
aussi dans le cadre de ce projet agro
écologique que nous présentons pour la
france le fameux plan emma qui
privilégie des projets collectifs de
méthanisation agricole ou plusieurs
agriculteurs se regroupent autour d'un
projet conçu dans une langue logique
d'ancrage territorial et dans le respect
de la diversité des territoires c'est
cette vision là que nous voulons mettre
en avant donc ils ne sont pas appropriés
de brider la reconnaissance du caractère
agricole des projets par l'ajout d'un
plafonnement de la puissance de
l'installation
voilà monsieur le sénateur ce qui est
nous semble correspondre à un souci à la
fois une logique agricoles et une
logique environnementale vu dans sa
globalité merci monsieur mini jeu mais
se voit cet amendement numéro 5 qui a
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement monsieur l'abbé pour une
explication de vote ou simplement pour
répondre à notre chère rapporteur didier
guillaume moi aussi je crois en l'homme
mais je me méfie par rapport à la parade
par rapport à l'aspect appât du gain
pour pour certains regroupement d'hommes
je vous remercie merci monsieur de
noeuds pour une explication de vote pour
le groupe ump
excusez moi je peu près contre cet
amendement mais je voudrais à cette
occasion redire une nouvelle fois qu'il
faut se méfier des comparaisons entre la
france et l'allemagne sur ce système de
méthanisation les différences sont
telles qu'il faut faire attention sur le
plan technique monsieur l'abbé moi je
participe aux travaux du
de l'office franco-allemand de des
énergies renouvelables 14 février
dernier on a fait point ambassades
d'allemagne une journée entière sur les
problèmes de méthanisation il y as en
allemagne 7240 méthaniseur au travail en
france c'est moins de quelques dizaines
ce jour là on a 10 10 est bon mais quant
à la taille des méthaniseurs est la
composition des choses qu'on mais il y a
des problèmes techniques pour gérer un
méthaniseur qui font qu en allemagne
contrairement en france on a autorisé la
culture dédié bon donc on trouve un
équilibre en apportant de l'énergie à
partir il vit en allemagne on estime
l'ambassadeur nous dit il faudrait voir
ces chiffres on estime qu'il ya sept
migrer carte de maïs qui servent à faire
des la méthanisation parlera point il
est difficile de gérer un méthaniseur
avec une exploitation agricole qui n'a
que des déjections animales notamment
des déjections animales de bovins donc
en france on a corrigé on a accepté des
cultures dédiées en cultures dérobées il
faut mettre tout ça dans l'ensemble pour
voir quelle est la bonne taille en plus
il y a des projets nécessaires avec des
petites villes dont les déchets ménagers
sont une richesse qu'on enfouit donc il
faut être très prudent pour parler de
taille si on compare pas les techniques
et les choses auxquelles on veut aboutir
donc moi je voterai contre cet
amendement parce qu'il faut laisser les
choses évoluer et elles vont se créa
c'est au fur et à mesure il nous faudra
plusieurs années pour que nous joueurs
rejoignons le bon niveau de
méthanisation l'objectif c'est de
méthaniser tous les déchets ménagers
plutôt que de les mettre à la poubelle
merci monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
cam oui nous soutiendront également cet
amendement tout en voulant attirer
l'attention du gouvernement sur quelques
travers de la méthanisation à tout prix
notamment pour l'élevage laitier c'est
une véritable catastrophe pour l'élevage
laitier si on pousse à la méthanisation
ça veut dire qu'on enferme les vaches
pendant trois ans on les maintient en
faire mais c'est plus le bien-être
animal c'est véritablement
catastrophique autant ça peut bien
correspondre à l'élevage porcin ou à
l'élevage de volailles je crois qu'il
faut qu'on soit très prudent là dessus
par ailleurs cet amendement il a
l'intérêt de laisser le pouvoir au
gouvernement de fixer par décret la
puissance maximale je pense que les
expériences communes de plusieurs
agriculteurs en matière de métallisation
sont également à encourager pour autant
pas avec en tenant compte de ce que j'ai
dit auparavant je pense à géotexia dans
le mené chez nous qui est une belle
expérience pour l'instant et je crois
que là il faut il faut bien faire la
part des choses de très nombreux
agriculteurs nous disent ce n'est pas
notre métier nous notre métier c'est de
produire du lait par exemple c'est pas
de produire de l'électricité
donc je crois qu'il faut il faut qu'on
tienne les deux bouts si je puis dire de
cette affaire et je soutiendrai donc cet
amendement numéro 101 merci monsieur le
sénateur monsieur le noir vous savez la
part très rapidement madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre je suis
tout à fait hostile à cet amendement
doit absolument incroyable il vient d'un
représentant du groupe écologiste on
sait que la biomasse un bel avenir en
france et que à l'intérieur à biomasse
et la méthanisation
or d'un point de vue technique confie
reconnaît qu il ya un seuil critique en
dessous duquel
l'investissement n'est pas rentable et
deuxièmement notre marque notre collègue
marcel deneux avez raison de souligner
c'est la question de l'apport des
produits qui entrent dans deux
digesteurs il faut qu'il y ait une
opération collective comme l'a très bien
rappelé d'ailleurs le ministre pour
réussir la méthanisation alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes en train d'en
fermer la méthanisation dans un étau qui
fera qu' elle ne sera pas rentable
qu'elle ne sera pas efficiente si
monsieur le sénateur je ne vois plus de
demandes d'explications de bac je mets
donc aux voix cet amendement numéro 100
qui a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient cet
amendement n'est pas adopté un
amendement numéro 27 rectifié monsieur
la serbe défend
madame la présidente mes chers collègues
nous nous
nous représentons cet amendement que
nous avions déjà déposé en première
lecture et qui avait été adopté par le
sénat malheureusement les députés ont
supprimé en deuxième lecture j'espère
que le sénat donc aujourd'hui revisitera
et confirmera son attitude lors de la du
premier passage cet amendement concerne
les groupements d'intérêts économiques
et environnementaux nous considérons que
léger léger i2e sont une excellente
initiative qui vont dans le sens de
l'innovation
et notre amendement vise justement à
donner pourrais je dire de la
prolificité au travail qui sera engagée
ces groupements ont vocation à appuyer
la mise en réseau des exploitations les
plus innovantes c'est quelque chose qui
peut devenir extrêmement important et
dans le but de faire bénéficier de ses
innovations le plus grand nombre
d'agriculteurs afin d'engager une
évolution massive des importations vers
la performance économique écologique et
social il est donc nous semble-t-il
nécessaire de rattacher des travaux d
j2ee et de capitaliser et de diffuser
les enseignements auprès d'organismes de
développement dont c'est la mission est
pour une réelle efficacité du dispositif
nous considérons que l'égérie de eux
doivent être mis en réseau afin qu'une
innovation imaginer sur un territoire
puissent bénéficier à d'autres et
susciter de nouvelles idées les g2 au
son d'une très belle initiative rendons
les productifs et rendons les donc
généralisable au plus en nombre par
l'intermédiaire notamment de notre
proposition d'amendement merci monsieur
le sénateur pour la commission monsieur
important merci madame la présidente
monsieur lasserre
si j'osais je vous demanderais bien de
retirer votre amendement
pourquoi parce que parfois on fait des
grands écarts mais nous l'avons le sénat
a voté en première lecture l'amendement
de monsieur césar et l'amendement de
monsieur lasserre sur ce sujet mais nous
n'étions pas très au point de lyon il
faut clarifier verrouillé de trois
choses et avancer entre temps nous avons
travaillé et l'assemblée nationale a
transformé
l'amendement des dents texte en ne
donnant pas le monopole parce que les
monopoles c'est jamais bon dans aucun
sens mais redonnant le pilotage aux
chambres d'agriculture
donc à partir de là il me semble avis du
rapporteur que appartements ou les
chambres d'agriculture ont le pilotage
de l'animation nous avons les garanties
et je vous demanderai de retirer votre
amendement pour ne pas donner le
monopole il me semble que dans là qu'on
appelle temps dans l'écriture de
l'assemblée nationale il n'est pas
totalement satisfait si on est très
objectif mais il est globalement
satisfait
le record est favorable à vis du
gouvernement peut-être qu'après je vous
redonne la parole monsieur la série glee
est favorable à la pression merci donc
pour une explication de vote tout une
réponse à la question qui vous a été
posée monsieur la sers
toi je le prenais de monsieur le
rapporteur tout aux situations de
monopole y compris pour la diffusion
quelque chose de fâcheux de
moi je ne suis pas absolument garanti
par leur décision qui a été prise et de
conférer ceci aux chambres d'agriculture
je serais même prêt à modifier un peu le
texte pour ouvrir le champ de la
diffusion des résultats des travaux des
jets ide si la réponse est favorable là
dessus et sucre a retiré l'amendement
bien entendu
monsieur le rapporteur
il va trouver sur leurs portes
le 15 oui c'est les alinéas 15-16-17 la
page 13 du texte delà de la commission
je lui permet de lire c'est madame la
présidente
alors le sait prévoir les modalités du
regroupement de diffusion de
réutilisation des résultats obtenus sur
les plans économiques environnementales
et sociales donc la linea 15 la
coordination des actions menées en vue
de la capitalisation et de la diffusion
des résultats des groupements des dg 2e
est assurée en lien avec les organismes
de développement agricole intéressé
alinéa 16 petits tas au niveau régional
par la chambre régionale d'agriculture
sous le contrôle du représentant de
l'état dans la région et du président du
conseil régional et petit b alinéa 17 au
niveau national par l'apc à l'assemblée
permanente des chambres d'agriculture
sous le contrôle du ministre chargé de
l'agriculture il me semble que cette
rédaction va donc soit retrait ou avis
défavorable
donc cet amendement est retiré
nous passons à l'amendement numéro 99
monsieur l'abbé pour le groupe
écologiste
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chers collègues le sénat
restreint la pratique de l'échangé des
semences entrailles entre agriculteurs
roger u2 eux seuls cette disposition
risque de détourner les g2 et de leur
finalité de détourner les subventions
j2ee de leur objectif final de plus cet
alinéa restreindrait la portée de
l'article l
325 1 du code rural qui définit
l'entr'aide entre exploitants en ce qui
concerne les changes de semences de
fermes et qui n'est pas limité un
périmètre ainsi cet amendement propose
de revenir sur la restriction imposée
par le sénat en première lecture
merci monsieur le sénateur pour la
commission avis du rapporteur monsieur
le président ghislain avis défavorable
monsieur la belle sait bien nous l'avons
vu en commission en première lecture
puis en séance en première lecture puis
en commission en deuxième lecture plus
nous voyons en séance en deuxième
lecture ça fait partie du débat la
navette gelé d'hier les deux précédentes
loi de 2006 et 2009 n'avait eu qu'une
lecture on n'aurait pas eu la chance si
on n'a vu qu'une lecture de reparler de
ce sujet pourquoi j'y suis défavorable
parce que de façon très encadrée à
l'intérieur des j2ee les changes de
semences est possible mais pas à
l'extérieur nous créons un marché
parallèle donc je ne suis pas d'accord
quand vous dites le sénat restera à vous
avez dit le sénat restreint
le sénat restera la poudre non le sénat
ne resterait rien le sénat revient à une
lecture assez clair pas des changes de
semences pas de marché parallèle en
dehors des génies 2e donc que c'est un
avis défavorable monsieur l'abbé merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur pour le
gouvernement monsieur le ministre oui
merci madame présente effectivement nous
sommes tout à fait défavorable à cet
amendement et je voudrais préciser qu'au
contraire le texte ouvrant aujourd'hui
un petit peu plus de possibilités
puisque
c'est uniquement une présomption
entraide termes juridiques précis validé
par le conseil d'état qui laisse une
part de responsabilité aux agriculteurs
alors que considérer relevé d'entre
elles serait de ce point de vue n'est
acceptable mais vous le notez nous
élargissons les
les possibilités et donc je pense que
vous devriez en prendre acte et
peut-être à votre tour retirer cet
amendement merci monsieur le ministre
je mets aux voix cet amendement numéro
99 monsieur l'abbé donc à la demande de
monsieur le ministre de retrait sur cet
amendement je vais le retirer bien que
j'ai encore quelques doutes mais je leur
tire et monsieur le sénateur amendement
numéro 127 toujours monsieur l'abbé pour
le groupe écologiste
s'ils sont 27 ou 222 parce que 127
excusez moi oui
activement de précisions sur la
définition de la méthanisation agricole
collective qui sera encouragée dans le
cadre des j2ee voilà donc c'est
simplement une précision à vis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
madame la présidente comme ça sera pas
toute la journée comme cela je voulais
dire avec un grand sourire et beaucoup
d'entrain du journée un avis favorable à
cet amendement de monsieur l'abbé merci
monsieur le rapporteur à vis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
favorable
donc je vais mettre aux voix cet
amendement qui a reçu deux avis
favorables
l'inde la commission l'autre du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient cet amendement est adopté
on continue avec monsieur l'abbé pour
l'amendement numéro 122
oui madame la présidente monsieur lien
sur collègues on en vient à la question
de la méthanisation
cet amendement vise à encourager la
reconversion des élevages sur quel les
élevages de porcs sur caillebotis en
élevage sur litière végétale dont le
potentiel méthanogène et la rentabilité
finale est meilleur en association avec
la méthanisation pour produire de
méthane il faut du carbone le lisier
comprend 95% d'eau tout le monde le sait
et le reste est très peu méthanogènes le
fumier obtenu en élevage sur paille pour
possède un prouve art méthanogènes bien
supérieur et c'est aussi un amendement
pour enrichir le le terreau et et
refaire l'humus dont on a besoin alors
en priorité refaire le terreau un fumier
et en supplément servir heureusement et
positivement à la méthanisation je crois
que là c'est une vraie bonne réponse et
sans parler du bien-être animal parce
que les élevages de porcs sur
caillebotis dans une société humaine
c'est pas terrible merci monsieur le
sénateur avis de la commission monsieur
ne rapportant madame la présidente
monsieur le sénateur c'est parce que
c'est une vraie bonne nouvelle un
vraiment à bandes manque je vais donner
un avis défavorable parce que je pense
que vous êtes non non mais sérieusement
je pense qu'ils vous devriez le retirer
monsieur l'abbé gc tenter de vous
expliquer pourquoi ils me disent
peut-être tout à l'heure le fera avec
beaucoup plus de succès que moi je
partage ce que vous dite pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas mais ce n'est pas dans la
loi enfin on va pas faire des lois
bavarde de 3000 pages on va dire ben on
va mettre les ports sur caillebotis et
puis pourquoi pas d'autres pourquoi pas
d'autres pourquoi pas d'autres ce n'est
pas de la loi ça c'est une pratique
agraire qui peut se faire une pratique
d'élevage donc moi je suis pas
défavorable à votre à votre proposition
qui peut être intéressante mais je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse mettre ça dans la
loi ça veut dire ce serait exclusif de
tout le reste non pour l'instant nous ne
sommes pas à même ne sommes pas capables
de mettre cela exclusive de tout le
reste donc c'est un bel amendement
d'appel je pense que c'est bien ce que
vous avez dit ça comptera beaucoup
d'éleveurs de votre sensibilité et
d'autres sensibilités mais vraiment
monsieur l'abbé je vous demande dans
l'intérêt global de retirer cet
amendement ça serait ennuyeux qu'on soit
obligé de voter contre que le sénat vote
contre quelque chose qui peut être
intéressant qui peut avoir de l'avenir
mais qui ne peut pas rentrer dans la loi
donc je fais pas comme ça pour endormir
mais c'est ça pourquoi pas mais pas dans
la loi donc retiré le vous l'avez
présentez vous l'avez argumenté vous
ferez une explication de vote et je
pense que ce sera bien merci monsieur le
rapporteur rabhi du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre président tué le
gouvernement est intéressé par l'idée
mais
par contre il souligner auprès du
législateur l'idée que nous ne pouvons
pas tout écrire dans la loi et que donc
ces précisions par ailleurs intéressante
n'ont pas à être inscrits dans le cadre
législatif est donc peut-être que vous
serez entendu et que le mieux ce serait
de retirer cet amendement
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
sénateur l'abbé corps et pendez vous à
cette question oui
madame et président monsieur le ministre
cher collègue monsieur le rapporteur
j'ai eu un moment de doute vous avez pu
constater ma bonne volonté pour ce qui
est des retraites et la la et puis
j'entends dire loi bavarde ce n'est pas
du tout du bavardage et est vraiment là
je ne peux pas le retirer cet amendement
je le maintiens merci donc je vais
mettre aux voix cet amendement qui a
reçu deux avis défavorables de la
commission et du gouvernement qui et
pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient cet
amendement n'est pas adopté nous en
avons nous en venons à deux amendements
identiques faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune d'abord l'amendement
numéro 86 madame nique où vous avez la
parole oui merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement propose de réintroduire
une disposition autorisant les échanges
de céréales entre membres de j2ee sans
être tenu un passage physique par un
collecteur agréé je vous rappelle que
cette disposition était présente dans le
projet de loi initial et a été supprimée
en première lecture à l'assemblée
nationale afin de répondre aux
inquiétudes soulevées par lors de son
examen nous l'avions réintroduite au
sénat en précisant que ces échanges
resteraient soumis aux déclarations
statistiques et au versement des taxes
prélevées en règle générale lors du
passage en organismes stockeurs nous
apportions ainsi une réponse deux
grandes inquiétudes soulevées par les
députés en première lecture or cette
disposition a de nouveau été supprimée
en séance publique à l'assemblée
nationale notamment au motif que cela
ouvrait la voie à une désorganisation du
marché des céréales nous ne partageons
pas cette analyse ise nous rappelons ici
que cet amendement ne permet pas une
commercialisation son passage par
l'organisme stocker en dehors d'un j2ee
c'est pourquoi nous vous proposons de
réintroduire cette disposition qui va
dans le sens d'une simplification du
fonctionnement des gènes de e afin de
favoriser l'action collective et la
complémentarité entre exploitations qui
madame la sénatrice monsieur le calme
pour l'amendement numéro 88 oui madame
la présidente monsieur denis charlet que
cet amendement vient de très bien
défendue par madame nique où il nous
savons de sommes très attachés également
à ces échanges de semences depuis très
longtemps c'est pourquoi nous sommes
autorisés à reprendre le même pour lui
donner davantage de poids davantage de
résonance au sein de notre assemblée et
faire en sorte aussi que au moment de la
cmp ils soient maintenues merci monsieur
le sénateur avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
à mussidan que c'est un avis favorable
sur ces deux amendements que nous avions
présenté en première lecture que le
sénat avait voté que l'assemblée a
retiré on verra ce qui se passera en cmp
moi je suis d'avis de leurs maîtres et
des garde-fous on ne peut pas faire
n'importe quoi donc nous avions bien
verrouiller sa en première en première
lecture c'est à l'interdît j2ee c'est la
différence de ce qui vaut kittler
monsieur monsieur l'abbé là c'est en
parle bien des changes à l'intérieur
d'un j2ee toute façon il faudra quand
même passer par les organismes
collecteurs madame d'ikoula très bien
présentés et également le groupe crc
donc je pense qu'il n'y a pas de risque
à des garde-fous et je propose de mettre
un avis favorable
important à vis du gouvernement monsieur
le ministre
le gouvernement y est favorable
merci merci je vais donc mettre au point
ces deux amendements
oui monsieur m'a dit vous avez la parole
pas être long seulement pour dire que je
voterai cet amendement parce qu'il me
semble simple simple vous savez que
d'alléger les deux heures on sait pas
trop encore exactement quel doit être
ses résultats et vous savez que notre
groupe nous avons encore quelques
interrogations là il ya quelque chose de
concrète positif est simple donc c'est
pourquoi personnellement je voterai cet
amendement même si monsieur le sénateur
je mets donc au voir ces deux
amendements qui ont reçu tous les deux
un avis favorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient ces deux amendements sont
adoptés nous en venons à l'amendement
numéro 125 présentée par monsieur l'abbé
pour le groupe écologiste pardon la
présidente monsieur le ministre chers
collègues cet amendement pourrait
paraître anecdotique il ne l'est pas du
tout et là encore m'appelant l'abbé je
pourrais avoir l'air de prêcher dans le
désert mais je sais que ce n'est pas
dans le désert parce que je sais que je
suis si ce n'est écouté au moins entendu
alors cet amendement vise à reconnaître
une pratique aujourd'hui largement
popularisé et de plus en plus largement
popularisé l'aide bénévole qui peut
prendre forme connue sous le nom connu
de wwoofing et qui se trouve
actuellement dans une situation
juridique très inconfortable si de
nombreux agriculteurs accueille ce qu'on
appelle les woofers ils manifestent de
plus en plus leurs craintes de voir
cette wright cet accueil et à juste
titre requalifier en travail déguisé par
la msa cet amendement permet donc de
clarifier le statut de l'aide bénévole
et d'encourager ce type des changes
profitable à la fois pour les
agriculteurs qui peuvent bénéficier de
coups de main transmettre leur passion
mais aussi refaire le lien entre la
population citadine ou périurbaines et
avec le métier d'agriculteur donc c'est
une nouvelle culture c'est en cours et
ça va se continuer simplement le fait de
pouvoir
maître sur la donner la possibilité d'un
contrat d'être bénévole que les
conditions sont fixées par décret et ça
permet de clarifier les choses a quelque
chose qui existe je vais vous donner un
tout petit exemple sur ma commune de
saint nolff quand j'étais encore mr on
appréhende t tout une ferme de 23
hectares en utilisant les outils de la
pile de la puissance publique pour y
installer une marie cher et au début
c'est au moins une vingtaine de
personnes qui sont venues spontanément
l'aider seulement 100 sans aucune sans
aucun cadre juridique et c'est le cas un
contrat de deux bénévoles et c'est plié
et et pour autant pour l'agriculteur que
pour les que pour les personnes on se
met au clair je vais m merci monsieur le
sénateur à vis
à vis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
la présidente monsieur monsieur le
sénateur la bévue en première lecture vu
en deuxième
lecture vous l'avez quasiment 10 vous
même dans votre argumentation
ça pourrait s'apparenter à du travail
dissimulé l'entr'aide ce n'est pas le
wwoofing et nous voulons rester sur la
première partie qui dit entraide dit
contrepartie des retours et là ce n'est
pas le cas la terre aux paysans c'est un
slogan nous avions entendu nous nous
sommes pour la terre aux paysans et que
les agriculteurs fassent ce qu'ils ont
en face ce qu'ils ont à faire moi je
suis défavorable à cette a7 à cet
amendement franchement si on pousse le
bouchon un peu loin la direction du
travail pourrait venir ça peut
s'apparenter à du travail dissimulé je
ne suis pas favorable nous ne sommes pas
dans le beau film nous sommes dans
l'antre aide restons là où nous en
sommes à vis des femmes merci monsieur
le sénateur monsieur rapportant à vis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
oui madame la présidente je pense que
c'est assemblée comme l'autre a voté
récemment un
texte de loi encadrant les stages
payants avec beaucoup de prudence sur
les rapports au travail de gens qui
viennent soit disant de façon bénévole
donc je ne comprends pas comment on peut
ouvrir dans le droit du travail à
travers cette idée qui est qui a toutes
les apparences de la générosité mais
elle est une ouverture par rapport au
travail qui est tout à fait
problématique donc nous sommes
défavorables si monsieur le ministre
je mets aux voix cet amendement qui a
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient cet
amendement n'est pas adoptée jeu mais on
voit l'article 3 du projet de loi qui et
pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient l'article 3 est adopté
nous en venons à l'article 4 avec cinq
amendements discussion commune je
commence par l'amendement numéro 10 est
rectifié monsieur lasserre vous avez la
parole
comme la présidente mes chers collègues
nous demandons la suppression des
alinéas 1 à 6 nous considérons on a eu
beaucoup de discussions de débats nous
considérons que les obligations déjà
existantes par exploitation sur les
cahiers d'épandage obligations imposées
par la réglementation et vérifiez
régulièrement par les contrôles suffit
je le crois à maîtriser le problème qui
nous et qui nous est posée
l'article 4 concerne l'obligation de
déclaration des flux d'azoté il oblige
les déclarations sur les stockages les
transports et nous considérons que
véritablement là on va très très loin
dans la complexité ça pourrait se
relever de l'inquisition et les mesures
déjà prises je le répète sur les plans
d'épandage devrait amplement suffire
pour apaiser les craintes ou les
objectifs de ceux qui considèrent qu'il
faut maîtriser ces situations
merci mais c'est le sénateur
l'amendement numéro 52 qui le défend
monsieur bailly
c'est le même bruit c'est le même
amendement et je crois qu'on a déjà eu
un débat en première lecture ces sujets
là vous savez que c'est un sujet aussi
où notre groupe nous y sommes et très
défavorable donc en deuxième lecture il
était aussi à reposer ce problème
aujourd'hui tout jean conduit hier notre
rapporteur monsieur guillaume me dire
combien cette loi on allait simplifier
dans l'agriculture et les agriculteurs
salé s'en trouver bien mieux avec tous
et cette simplification or l'art déjà
quelque chose qui va du doubs dans ce
sens là parce que c'est des déclarations
supplémentaires aujourd'hui dans toutes
les exploitations agricoles
il s'y lie à les plans d'épandage avec
toutes les unités qui sont mises je
crois qu'il ya déjà suffisamment de
travail qui est fait de transparence ce
encore obligé ses déclarations chante en
duo en première lecture que c'était les
prestataires enfin ceux qui libre qui
avait ses déclarations mais compte ce
n'est à mon avis ça vaut de là et c'est
pourquoi je nous avons présenté cette
suppression des halles hier de 1,6 comme
le collègue lasserre vient aussi de les
défendre merci de nous confirmer merci
monsieur le sénateur amendement numéro
peut-être pas si amendement numéro 103
monsieur l'abbé excusez moi donc je vais
pas vous relire l'ensemble de l'objet
simplement vous dire qu'en bretagne on
est aux premières loges des méfaits des
excédents d'azoté que l'on paye encore
même s'il ya eu des améliorations et des
excédents divers de de l'élevage
excessivement intensifs donc c'est
pourquoi bill et pour nous fondamentale
a minima de rendre systématique cette
déclaration de flux d'azoté dans les
zones vulnérables
qui monsieur le sénateur en amendement
numéro 164 présentée par monsieur
guillaume a au nom de la commission des
affaires économiques
merci amendement numéro 53 monsieur le
noir oui mais là le président monsieur
minivert collègues cet amendement est
tiré de la même tonne de cidre que les
amendements précédent en fait il s'agit
d'aller plus loin et de vérifier pour le
cas où ces dispositions figurant dans
les amendements précédent qui ont été
défendus n'était pas adopté est-ce que
derrière le texte qui nous vient de
l'assemblée nationale il y aurait l'idée
que ces déclarations soient utilisés
pour ensuite effectuer des prélèvements
d'ordre fiscal en particulier ou à
travers des prélèvements parafiscaux au
détriment des agriculteurs
le seul sénateur à vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur sur ces cinq
amendements à président donc cinq
amendements discussion commune qui
disent totalement
l' inverse les uns des autres mais c'est
le même thème donc c'est normal qu'il
soit en discussion commune sur les deux
premiers de monsieur bailly et de
monsieur
lasserre je ne peux pas vous laisser
dire mais nous avons que j'ai eu ce
débat je ne peux pas vous laisser dire
c'est des contraintes supplémentaires
pause agriculteurs parce que ce n'est
pas vrai ce n'est pas vrai c'est pas non
ce n'est pas vrai c'est pas ce qui est
écrit dans la loi les agriculteurs sont
obligés de faire leurs démarches et
n'inscrit d'un plan d'épandage mais
maintenant non mais maintenant pas après
cette loi aujourd'hui bon simplement là
ce qui est dit dans le texte c'est ce
sont les fournisseurs ah oui mais ce ne
sont pas des sculpteurs vous avez dit on
mais des contraintes supplémentaires aux
aviculteurs ce n'est pas vrai ce sens
pour les fournisseurs c'est pas un
problème en soi me semble-t-il par
ailleurs cette mesure permettra de mieux
assurer le respect de la directive
nitrates le ministre en parlera tout à
l'heure non mais la france peut être
condamné on peut on peut se ficher de
l'europe etc mais la france pourrait
être condamné et il vaut mieux assurer
les choses je vous dirai tout à l'heure
comment on pourrait ne pas être condamné
sur le loup par l'europe mais là dessus
vous pourriez être qu'on est donc le
ministre va donner ses argumentations je
ne partage pas votre argumentation ce
dispositif ne va pas dans le bon sens je
crois mais nous avons eu ce débat en
première lecture donc je donne deux avis
défavorables sur
monsieur l'abbé alors là c'est à
linverse c'est l'obligation pour le
préfet d'imposer la déclaration annuelle
de fuites d'azoté toujours par
pragmatisme et par souci d' équilibre je
n'y suis pas favorable et celui de
monsieur le noir que je connais trop
pour savoir que dans son intervention il
ne fait aucun procès d'intention
évidemment mais il est évidemment
voilà mais évidemment mais comme vous le
vous le dites dans votre amendement de
façon erronée pour qui une taxation fric
une loi donc on ne peut pas dire est ce
que l'assemblée voudrait mettre une taxe
non c'est pas possible ce n'est pas dans
la dans la loi ce n'est pas dans le mode
à venir donc je pense que cet amendement
honnêtement maintenant qu'il a été
présenté et argumentée pourrait très
bien être retiré et si une nouvelle loi
devait amener une taxation nous dirions
ce que nous en pensons en tout cas s'il
n'est pas retirée moi j'aimais très un
avis un avis défavorable parce que votre
amendement présente pas d'intérêt
juridique
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente oui on touche
à un sujet qui est très emblématique
quand même dans les débats de l'opinion
publique autour de l'agriculture et je
pense que chacun a compris ici que la
position du gouvernement était
parfaitement d'une part ciblé il s'agit
d'intervenir dans les territoires où il
ya des problèmes majeurs induits par les
flux d'azoté donc on ne pose pas le
problème d'un point de vue principe yale
théorique sur l'ensemble du territoire
national deuxièmement les choses se sont
ciblés correspondant sera porteuse
rappeler à l'instant à une politique
aussi qu'ils aient entendu au plan
européen elle le fait dans le souci de
l'environnement ou à tous les sens du
terme est d'abord l'environnement des
agriculteurs concernés
y at il une surcharge de travail non
c'est très spécifiquement écrit dans la
loi ce n'est pas aux agriculteurs de
faire cette déclaration
y at il une taxe non c'est très
clairement qu'il n'y a absolument rien
sur ce sujet dans la loi et donc faire
des présupposés alors même que cette
assemblée aura si jamais la question se
pose et peut-être par une autre majorité
monsieur le sénateur et bien nous
verrions à ce moment là ce que dirait
l'assemblée nationale mais puisque vous
y pensez peut-être que vous pourriez
penser demain qui sait ah je vous
connais je vous ai connu aussi nous
étions ensemble donc si vous prêtez
parfois des reproches que vous faites à
d'autres je n'en sais rien
donc un nous voyons là en tout cas que
les propositions du texte de loi sont
parfaitement me semble-t-il équilibré
donc je donne un avis défavorable nom du
gouvernement sur les trois amendements
qui ont été proposées sur l'avant sur
l'amendement de la commission avis
favorable
bien je vais donc mettre aux voix ces
amendements d'abord les deux amendements
17 rectifié 52 qui sont identiques qui
ont reçu des avis défavorables de la
commission et du gouvernement qui et
pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient ces deux
amendements ne sont pas adopté
l'amendement numéro 103 2 avis
défavorable du de la commission et du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient cet amendement n'est pas
adopté un amendement de la commission
des affaires économiques 164 qui a reçu
un avis favorable du gouvernement qui et
pour
qui et contre cet amendement est adopté
et enfin un amendement numéro 53 qui a
reçu deux avis défavorables la
commission et du gouvernement
monsieur noir est ce que voudra tirer
une eau
non non je ne le retire jeu puisque vous
me donnez la parole pendant leur
présidence yeux la première volontiers
simplement j'ai pris acte avec vous tous
ce sera au journal officiel qui n'avait
absolument pas l'intention
de la part de ce gouvernement de
procéder ensuite à
des prélèvements d'ordre fiscal ou
d'ordre parafiscales merci de ces
précisions
senator jeu mais on voit cet amendement
53 qui et pour qui et contre cet
amendement n'est pas adopté nous en
venons à l'amendement numéro 102
toujours sur cet article quatre
monsieur l'abbé vous avez la parole pour
groupes écologistes oui madame la
ministre madame pardon madame la
présidente pas encore excusez moi
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
donc il s'agit de définir pour nous un
plafond maximal d'épandage annuel d'à
zone minérale et organique par hectare
en fonction des situations locales et de
leur évolution pour être pour être
précis parce que le seuil limite
existants soit 170 kg d'azoté par ha
représentent seulement la zot organique
donc ce que l'on souhaite c'est qu'il y
à un plafond pour le cumul et organiques
et minérales
chez le sénateur avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
présidente c'est un avis défavorable
pour des raisons très pratiques la
possibilité de définir une quantité
maximum d autres totale apportée par
hectare pour être intéressante notamment
dans les zones de marais vers dans les
zones de forte pollution on sait que
c'est un vrai problème sauf que on sait
très bien que ce n'est pas possible de
faire la zone totale d'abord je vais
prendre mon papier d'abord il existe des
plafonds en matière d'azoté minéral sur
les cultures avant le 1er mars 50 unités
sur le blé et l'orge 80 unités sur le
colza et après le 1er mars sans unité
par hectare maximum donc il existe déjà
des plafonds mais pour l'azoté minéral
on ne peut pas le faire pour les autres
total et par ailleurs on sait très bien
que l'azoté minéral se fixent mieux sur
la plante que l'azoté organique c'est la
raison pour laquelle sa part je pense
d'une d'un intérêt mais je vous
demanderai de le retirer pour des
raisons pratiques et de faisabilité si
vous ne le retire y est pas j'émettrais
un avis défavorable parce qu'il ya déjà
des plafonds qui s'applique
important avait du gouvernement monsieur
le ministre défavorable
je vais mettre aux voix cet amendement
numéro 100 de monsieur l'abbé vous savez
la parole
après la demande de monsieur le
rapporteur et dans le cadre de la
cordialité de nos échanges je vais
retirer cet amendement
merci monsieur le sénateur je vous avais
toujours la parole pour l'amendement
numéro 100
alors justement
il s'agit on en revient donc au sujet de
la méthanisation
on a évoqué tout à l'heure l'exemple
allemand où des hectares de maïs des
milliers d'hectares de maïs sont
cultivées pour alimenter les
méthaniseurs la terre on a évoqué la
pose et la protection la préservation de
la terre de la terre agricole
communautaire qui doit être avant tout
nourricière 7 milliards d'habitants sur
la planète 9 milliards attendus en 2050
chaque chaque hectare haute de terre
nourricière aura son importance alors
pour nous la mettre la méthanisation que
l'on reconnaît à sa juste valeur on
tient à ce que que l'alimentation en
soit limitée
uniquement à des déchets des cultures
intermédiaires et quand même à titre
exceptionnel une dérogation à 7,1 à
cette interdiction peut être délivré
dans des conditions prévues par décret
c' est un amendement qui est extrêmement
mesurer et qui enrichit le texte vous
remercie merci monsieur le sénateur avis
de la commission monsieur le rapporteur
je vais attendre l'avis du gouvernement
tout à l'heure mais je vous demande un
avis de retrait sinon défavorable on a
déjà examiné cet amendement vous
proposer de ne reconnaître comme
méthaniseur dans le cadre des j2ee que
des installations alimentées par des
déchets ou des cultures intermédiaires
on comprend bien une idée pas de soucis
ne pas encourager à produire par exemple
des céréales pour aller pour alimenter
directement des méthaniseurs au lieu de
contribuer à l'alimentation humaine nous
en avons parlé sauf que vous voulez
éviter des dérives
sauf que dans le cadre de l'agrément des
j2ee c'est pour ça que j'attends l'avis
du gouvernement les j'ai eu 2 e ne
serait pas
n'aurait pas l'agrément si c'était par
des cultures comme tel donc je pense que
votre amendement vous pouvez le retirer
après que les ministres vous et donnez
vous ai rassurés parce qu'il est de fait
satisfait évidemment si le gouvernement
à gré des j'ai eu 2 e à l'intérieur
desquels y aurait des méthaniseurs qui
serait alimenté par des cultures direct
je crois que ça serait à l'encontre de
ce que sont les génies 2e donc à mon
avis le gouvernement va vous rassurer
donc vous allez le retirer mais au cas
vous ne le retire y est pas j'émettrais
un avis défavorable dit monsieur le
rapporteur à vis du gouvernement
monsieur ministre
présidente
monsieur le sénateur nous partageons les
objectifs qui sont les vôtres néanmoins
nous ne pensons pas que nous puissions
accepter cet amendement
en fait la méthanisation agricole est
déjà très encadrée à la fois par
l'article 301 du code rural et par les
conditions de financement à ce stade les
méthaniseurs sont pour l'essentiel a
alimenté par des effluents de la
biomasse et des déchets de cultures
intermédiaires à vocation énergétique
il se peut que des ruptures puisse se
faire dans ses approvisionnements aussi
il importe de ne pas s'interdire
absolument de compléter les apports par
les cultures aussi nous sommes des
favoris nous partageons votre
philosophie mais nous pensons que ce qui
est dit dans votre amendement est trop
rigoureux et peut entraîner des
dysfonctionnements si peut-être que là
aussi après avoir rappelé à travers
votre amendement la philosophie de ce
système de métallisation et bien
il pourrait être utile de le retirer
monsieur merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le sénateur
oui j'ai entendu mais à voir la grande
satisfaction de monsieur bizet
d'entendre le rapporteur sa main qui
était donc je vais maintenir cet
amendement
vient donc je vais m je vais mettre aux
voix cet amendement qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables
l'un de la commission l'autre du
gouvernement qui pour cet amendement qui
est contre cet amendement n'est pas
adoptée nous en venons à 4 amendement
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
d'abord l'amendement numéro 54 c'est
monsieur bailly qu'il défend vous avez
la parole chers collègues
oui madame la présidente monsieur mini
chers collègues c'est un sujet sur les
les beaux
environnementaux
beaucoup évoqué en première lecture je
crois l'avoir évoqué également dans mon
intervention hier c'est vrai que pour
nous il est encore un certain nombre
d'interrogations
c'est pourquoi nous pensons que là aussi
ce n'est pas de la simplification mais
que nous pouvons avoir des contraintes
ou des conflits qui puissent se passer
entre le propriétaire du terrain elles
preneur et c'est pourquoi cet amendement
propose de supprimer les alinéas de 9 à
même si déjà le bail environnemental
les lieux on a avancé quand même dans
pendant dans des améliorations qu'aller
dans le sens que nous souhaitions il
reste quand même aujourd'hui un certain
nombre d'interrogations
car heures en première lecture donc
comme je viens de dire le sénat a
assoupli cette généralisation les deux
conditions légales actuelles sont
maintenues
une troisième est serré la troisième
condition permet d'insérer des clauses
environnementales
dans un bail pour pérenniser des
pratiques respectueuses de
l'environnement existantes et c'est vrai
que dans l'alinéa
11 on y trouve bien sûr la ressource en
eau la biodiversité alors la ressource
en eau je dirais que c'est tout naturel
je crois que là-dessus on va tous on va
tous se retrouver pour être d'accord sur
la biodiversité suivant comment on voit
les choses il peut y avoir des
différences très importantes vous le
savez mais aussi pour les paysages là
aussi on voit des interprétations
différence la qualité des produits on se
retrouve à may a aussi l'air alors là
aussi quelles appréciations qu'est ce
qu'on va demander au bail au bailleur
par rapport à la qualité de l'air
prévention des risques naturels
enfin il semble aussi qu'on ouvre une
l'air peut faire une grande boîte de
pandore où il peut y avoir un petit peu
n'importe quoi qu'il soit mis dans des
exigences dans ses beaux
environnementaux alors c'est pourquoi
nous souhaitons que ces amendements
soient retirés bien sûr nous sommes
favorables lorsqu'il y en accord entre
le bailleur et le preneur s'ils veulent
inclure des clauses d'un commun accord
il n'y a pas de problème mais quand je
rencontre aujourd'hui déjà un certain
nombre de personnes mais ce n'est pas du
lieu que la semaine dernière quelqu'un
qui me disait avoir aménagé 30 hectares
dans des parcelles en y faisant défaut c
est d avoir drainé et qu'aujourd'hui on
ne peut plus rien y faire et
qu'aujourd'hui c'est qu'une ces terrains
deviennent en grande difficulté eh bien
je crois aussi que là aussi quand on à
faire parfois aussi dans des
propriétaires qui peuvent être aussi un
petit peu intégriste ça nous amène à
quelques craintes alors c'est pourquoi
nous aurions souhaité que notre
assemblée
nous nous supprimions ses alinéas tout
en gardant bien vendredi la possibilité
comme je les dis à quelques instants
entrepreneurs et bailleurs s'ils sont
d'accord ensemble des maîtres des
clauses mais je crois que ce serait
beaucoup trop large merci
merci madame la présidente mes chers
collègues cet amendement concerne le
bail environnemental et plus
particulièrement l'inclusion des clauses
permettant la préservation de la
ressource en eau de la bio diversité des
paysages de la qualité des produits des
sols et de l'air la prévention des
risques naturels et la lutte contre
l'érosion
l'alinéa 11 de l'article 4 prévoit
l'inclusion de ces clauses
environnementales dans les beaux que ce
soit au moment de leurs conclusions ou
au moment de leur renouvellement cette
précision n'a pas de valeur juridique
car en droit le renouvellement d'un
contrat est équivalent à sa conclusion
est de plus si elle peut être incluse à
ces deux moments autant ne pas le
préciser très bien madame un fer à je
vais vous demander de présenter aussi
l'amendement numéro 69 rectifié puisque
l'amendement 3 rectifié tombe oui tout à
fait madame la présidente et c'est à
travers cet amendement monsieur savary
souhaitait vraiment insister sur ce
point et dans le cas contraire à cet
assaut cette contractualisation
cela risquait d'être source de nombreux
contentieux dans la mesure où le preneur
ne pourrait pas faire évoluer son
système de production où ces pratiques
de gestion sans compromettre sur
l'exploitation si cela ne se faisait pas
à ce moment précis de la conclusion du
bail
merci madame la sénatrice
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur sur ces trois amendements
alors bon ben moi je voudrais dire à
monsieur bailly que la première lecture
nous avions trouvé une position de
compromis nous avions modifié le texte
du gouvernement le texte de l'assemblée
et je propose que nous en restions là
parce que nous étions d'accord sur la
formulation prix en lecture du bail
environnemental tels que nous avions mis
les garde-fous et là maintenant vous
tout à fait votre droit évidemment vous
revenez là dessus en disant supprime les
envier les les alinéas donc on supprime
le bail environnemental
non je ne suis pas favorable je crois
pas qu'il faille le faire l'équilibrage
matic nous avions trouvé mal et m'allait
très bien donc je mets un avis
défavorable sur l'article 25 rectifié
jeu l'amendement pardon merci monsieur
le président de la commission
l'amendement 25 rectifié j'ai mieux aimé
un avis favorable
je crois que c'est du bon sens la
lecture la rédaction de l'assemblée
nationale nous semble un peu
superfétatoire le renouvellement de bail
est un nouveau bail donc la précision
apportée par les députés n'amène pas
donc je suis plutôt favorable quant au
69 rue de 4,69 le 3 est tombé le 69
rectifier bah si comme je l'espère nous
votons l'amendement 25 rectifier le 69
rectifié tombera donc je demande ce
serait une deux une demande de retrait à
madame ferrat au profit du 25 rectifier
il monsieur le rapporteur à vis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente nous sommes
défavorable à l'amendement numéro 54 on
a déjà eu l'occasion de le dire en
première lecture je ne pense pas qu'ils
aient dû rupture mais il ya au contraire
favoriser des évolutions positives dans
les sens des intérêts des deux parties
et par contre nous faisons mettront à
sagesse du sénat s'agissant de
l'amendement 25 rectifier merci monsieur
le ministre je vais donc mettre on voit
ces amendements l'amendement numéro 54
qui a reçu deux avis défavorables de la
commission et du gouvernement qui et
pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient cet amendement n'est pas
adopté l'amendement numéro 25 rectifié
qui a reçu un avis favorable la
commission invite sa chaise sans fin de
l'assemblée de la part du gouvernement
qui et pour
qui et contre cet amendement est adopté
et donc l'amendement 69 rectifié ton
vous êtes d'accord mais on verra nous
passons à deux amendements en discussion
commune toujours sur l'article 4
l'amendement numéro 59 monsieur bailly
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je crois que c'est uniquement
pour préciser les choses remplacer les
mots lettre recommandée par actuelle
avec accusé de réception par les mots
extra judiciaires afin de limiter les
contentieux de pur formalisme et
l'indispensable de déterminer le moyens
par lesquels le preneur doit notifier sa
demande au propriétaire lac
extrajudiciaires le moyen déjà utilisée
par le propriétaire pour notifier son
congé aux fermiers il ya pour avantage
de ne pas causer d'ambiguïté sur la date
qui doit être prise en considération
pour le point de départ de la
prescription
contrairement une lettre recommandée
avec avis de réception donc il nous
semblait que c'était pour aller dans un
sens de et d'éviter des contentieux à
l'appréciation de notre assemblée si
monsieur le sénateur amendement du
gouvernement numéro 160 monsieur le
ministre
absolument merci donc l'amendement 161
amendements de précision qui permet aux
propriétaires de pouvoir apprécier en
toute connaissance de cause si le coc
preneur restant rempli les conditions
lui permettant de reprendre le bail à
son seul nom et de saisir le tribunal
paritaire des baux ruraux en temps utile
s'il estime opportun l'ajout d'un
formalisme minimum sécurisé la situation
du bailleur le délai de saisine du tp br
de nature réglementaire sera précisé par
décret il s'agit donc d'un animant la
maman demande de clarification alors
s'agissant de l'amendement 59 pour tout
vous dire le sénateur nous pensons
exactement le contraire
c'est tout à fait d'ailleurs
l'esprit dans lequel s'est exprimé le
ministre de l'économie
monsieur montebourg et avant lui de
nombreux rapports et singulièrement
celui de la cour des comptes et de
l'inspection générale des finances qui
nous apprend qu'il y a aujourd'hui un
certain nombre d'actes ou de procédure
qui coûte très cher à nos compatriotes
en l'occurrence en espèces et c'est donc
les agriculteurs qui seraient amenés à
payer un acte d'huissier qui quelque
part serait de là aux alentours de 15
200 euros au lieu d'une lettre
recommandée de 4 euros cinq ans avouez
que vous qui êtes des attaches et bien
sûr vous l'avez souvent dit mais là je
ne comprends pas bien alors à moins que
évidemment il se soit le résultat cet
amendement d'une sollicitation d'une
profession et là quelle profession fait
la démonstration à travers cet
amendement que finalement des actes
simples pourraient être existé sans
qu'il y ait forcément des procédures du
site justice donc cela me semble
inopportun pour la profession est
inopportun pour les agriculteurs que
d'avoir à accepter cet amendement merci
monsieur le ministre j'ai quand même
demandé l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur sur ces deux amendements
la commission c'est favorable à celui du
gouvernement donc de fait celui de
monsieur bailly sera soit retiré soit
n'a plus de raison d'être mais
franchement le fait de faire payer les
agriculteurs avec l'acte comme ça à 1000
ou 1500 euros alors qu'un simple timbre
et une lettre recommandée suffit à mon
avis je pense que enfin moi je vous
demande de le retirer quel avis
favorable sur le gouvernement mais comme
le veau de passavant
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
disait vous avez la parole
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre chers collègues sur lui vous
avez raison il ya une différence de coût
et qui est très claire entre une lettre
recommandée une prestation d'un huissier
si vous voulez mais je crois qu'il faut
regarder également cela au travers du
risque beaucoup plus élevé qui serait
celui d'un contentieux pour une non
précision précisément de la réception
d'une décision travers d'une lettre
recommandée je crois que l'objet de cet
amendement ce n'est pas de défense de
défendre une profession l'objet de cet
amendement c'est de clarifier
précisément un risque de contentieux qui
peut exister au travers d'une délivrance
d'une lettre recommandée que par
hypothèse on voit ça quand même assez
facilement eh bien il n'y a personne
pour la réceptionner voyez ce que je
veux dire sur le sénateur monsieur
bailly retirer votre amendement comme
vous il ya un site et
oui avec les précisions garden et
monsieur le ministre on va gérer leur
fin c'était mon collègue césar puisqu'il
a eu certaines exemple justement de
contentieux sur ces sujets là qui
avaient été posés cet amendement qu'il
me semblait que nous sembler justifié
mais fort des arguments qui ont été
développées je retire l'amendement merci
monsieur le sénateur je vais donc mettre
aux voix l'amendement numéro 160 du
gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient cet
amendement est adopté
deux amendements identiques faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune le
numéro 23 madame sarah merci mais mme la
présidente mais chez recoller avec ces
dispositions prévues par le projet de
loi viennent bouleverser les
dispositions régissant aujourd'hui la
mise à disposition des baux en effet la
mise à disposition ou l'apport de droit
au bail ne peut se faire qu'au profit
d'une société à objet principalement
agricoles or le projet doit bien étendre
le régime de la mise à disposition à
toute personne morale à vocation
principalement agricoles cette
disposition introduite en première
lecture à l'assemblée nationale a été
supprimée par le sénat compte tenu de
l'insécurité juridique qu'elle engendre
puisqu'elle ouvre le champ aux
association de loi 1901 aux sociétés
coopératives etc de nombreux schémas de
mise à disposition ou d'apport dubai
pourrait alors se développer au profit
de sociétés non exploitante en
contradiction totale avec les
dispositions du statut du fermage qui
prévoit l'exploitation effective et
personnels du bien loué au sein même de
la société bénéficiaire de la mise à
disposition d'une part celle ci est une
atteinte à la liberté d'exploitation du
preneur dans le sens où il n'a pas
nécessairement dans la structure
bénéficiaire de la mise à disposition le
pouvoir d'orienter l'activité agricole
et d'autre part des sous-locations
formellement prohibé par le statut du
fermage d'ordre public pourrait se
généraliser
généralisée sans contrôle cette
disposition n'est maintenant ni d'une
demande de la profession ni de la
propriété devrait être retirée compte
tenu de l'insécurité juridique qu'elle
instaure si madame la sénatrice
l'amendement numéro 145 monsieur colin
vous avez la main dans la main ce midi
sa collègue effectivement ça vient
d'être rappelé en première lecture nos
collègues députés avaient large et les
possibilités de mise à disposition par
le preneur du bail rural dont était
titulaire à toute personne morale à
vocation principalement agricoles et non
plus exclusivement aux groupements
agricoles aux sociétés civiles
d'exploitation est donc autorisée dans
ces nouvelles conditions le portage des
opérations d'installation d'agriculteurs
risque de créer une insécurité juridique
en permettant par exemple et ça a été
rappelé aussi des sous locations
normalement interdite faut-il le
rappeler par le statut du fermage et
dans sa sagesse c'est bien connu le
sénat avait supprimé cette disposition
et vous aviez monsieur le rapporteur
d'ailleurs souligné à cette occasion que
la modification introduite à l'article
411 38 du code rural faisait sauter les
contreparties exigées des propriétaires
l'assemblée a rétabli l'article certes
un restaurant quelques gardons néanmoins
pourquoi maintenir ce dispositif qui
fragilise l équilibre entre bailleur et
preneur
alors que le code rural prévoit déjà des
mises à disposition rien ne démontre que
les règles actuelles ne suffisent pas et
c'est pourquoi nous proposons les aliens
à cause les alinéas concernés à cet
article 4
merci monsieur le sénateur avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
sur ces deux amendements 23 rectifié 145
madame la présidente
je vais demander à madame ferrat et à
monsieur
colin de retirer ces deux amendements et
s'il ne les retiraient pas j'émettrais
un avis défavorable pourquoi ce que vous
l'avez non vous l'avez très bien dit
l'un et l'autre
là elle semblait à première lecture vais
me un texte ce texte n'était pas à notre
sens assez performant nous y sommes donc
revenu dessus et nous avons bien fait
c'est ça l'intérêt des deux lectures
parce que nous améliorons les textes et
en fonction de ce que nous avions dit en
deuxième lecture à l'assemblée nationale
les députés sont allés au delà de ce que
nous faisions et on ya deux garde-fous
la mise à disposition du bail rural je
vais d'élire le bénéficiaire de la mise
à disposition doit être une personne
morale à objets agricoles la terre l'eau
et restera donc à objets à usage
agricole d'un premier garde-fous et le
deuxième en tout état de cause l'accord
du bailleur et requis la mise à
disposition du bail ne pourra pas se
faire dans son dos il s'agit donc là
d'une ouverture tout à fait maîtrisée me
semble-t-il et je pense que nous
pourrions prendre le risque de
l'innovation en ayant bien encadré cette
innovation qui permettra de développer
les initiatives d'associations et
organismes qui cherchent à alléger le
poids financier de l'acquisition
foncière qui pèse beaucoup sur les
agriculteurs aussi je vous demanderai à
l'une et à l'autre de bien vouloir
retirer votre amendement sans ça je me
verrais contraint à regret d'émettre un
avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur à vis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre mais
ma vie même avis rentrée ou avis
défavorable alors mes chers collègues
même ferrat vous retirer et monsieur
cola 1
ces deux amendements sont retirés nous
abordons aux quatre amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 22
rectifié madame ferrat
merci madame la présidente mes chers
collègues nous ne comprenons pas
pourquoi ces alinéas sont apparus à
l'assemblée nationale à l'initiative du
gouvernement sans concertation il vise à
réformer le mode de désignation des
assesseurs aux tribunaux paritaires des
baux ruraux par cette mesure la
désignation des assesseurs sera réalisé
par le juge sur une liste établie par le
préfet sur la base des propositions
formulées par les organisations
syndicales représentatives et les
fédérations de bailleurs ce mécanisme
semble à la fois complexe et injuste les
assesseurs sont jusqu'à présent élus
tous les six ans et siège aux côtés du
président du tribunal d'instance ces
tribunaux composé d'un magistrat
professionnel et de représentants élus
par les bailleurs et les preneurs
permettent une bonne administration de
la justice dans une réglementation
complexe et reposant sur des situations
qui nécessitent de bien connaître
l'activité agricole sur la forme cette
manière de procéder est inacceptable
alors que des groupes de travail se sont
tenues sur l'évolution des tribunaux
voilà plus de deux ans et qu aucune
rencontre n'a eu lieu depuis le
gouvernement a proposé une réforme
fondamentale des tribunaux paritaires
sans aucune concertation préalable
sur le fond une telle modification aura
pour effet de remplacer les actuels
magistrat reconnues pour leur compétence
et surtout élus par leurs pairs par des
personnes proposées par les
organisations syndicales représentatives
figurant sur une liste dans laquelle
juste professionnel devra choisir en
toute indépendance quand bien même les
candidats actuels peuvent faire mention
d'une appartenance syndicale lors des
élections ils sont élus par les
agriculteurs et propriétaires pour leur
compétence et non sur la base d'une
étiquette dans le dispositif électoral
actuel les candidats assesseurs
souhaitant se revendiquer d'un autre
syndicat peuvent le faire mais dans tous
les cas l'appartenance syndicale si elle
permet notamment la formation continue
des assesseurs n'est pas un gage de
compétence le mécanisme de désignation
proposé ne peut qu'aboutir à une
politisation préjudiciable à une bonne
administration de la justice dans les
tribunaux paritaires pourtant reconnue
tant par les juges que par les bailleurs
aux preneurs pour son efficience
trice monsieur bailly pour l'amendement
62 rectifié qui est identique
il est exactement le même que celui
qu'elle vient de défendre notre collègue
madame ceram scora qu'un jeu mais je
veux quand même redire ici que je
regrette vraiment que le gouvernement
n'ait pas proposé ce
cet amendement en première lecture parce
que c'est vrai qu'il ya un vrai débat
moi je suis j'ai suivi un petit peu ça
dans ma vie professionnelle
et c'est vrai que c'est assez complexe
aujourd'hui les élections aux tribunaux
paritaires on c'est vrai que le collège
des bailleurs le collège des preneurs
c'est une complexité donc ça me sort est
méritée je crois une vraie discussion
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est arrivé à
l'assemblée nationale et vu le temps qui
nous est imparti je répète encore rendre
le temps de l'assemblée nationale est le
temps qu'on nous sommes aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas pu beaucoup
l'évoqué sur le terrain avec les
organismes agricoles et on parle des
organisations syndicales mais moi je
suis plus si vous voulez chambre
d'agriculture puisque c'est quand même
elle représente ont en leur sein vu
leurs compositions les coller des
exploitants il ya des propriétaires il
ya des salariés tout le monde et aux
chambres d'agriculture
donc pourquoi aussi ne viendrait pas des
chambres d'agriculture pourquoi les
organisations syndicales avec tous les
problèmes que cela va poser alors moi je
pense qu'ils avaient besoin d'une
réflexion sur ce sujet là je pense qu'il
fallait faire l'étude d'impact c'est
peut-être pas le terme qui convient mais
aussi combien aujourd'hui tout est ce
mécanisme
des élections beau paritaire alors on
nous demande d'approuver cet amendement
du gouvernement dans la précipitation et
c'est ça que je regrette et que c'est
pourquoi nous disions qu'aujourd'hui
c'était peut-être fallait continuer la
réflexion mais en attendent vraiment de
savoir s'il aura pas des problèmes tels
que c'est prévu en attente on pensait
qu'il fallait supprimer si les amis et
les as de 28 à 43 qui sont arrivés à
notre connaissance comme il ya que très
très peu de jo si monsieur senator
amendement numéro 144 identique
également monsieur colin oui je rappeler
qu'en seconde lecture à l'assemblée
nationale nos collègues députés ont
décidé ça vient d'être appelé
sur proposition du gouvernement
d'ailleurs de mettre fin à l'élection
des assesseurs des tribunaux paritaires
des baux ruraux pour proposer une
nouvelle procédure de désignation des
assesseurs représentant d'un côté les
propriétaires de l'autre côté les
preneurs d arguments ont été avancés ont
été rappelés le faible taux de
participation à cette élection le coût
de l'organisation
on peut entendre ces raisons
m'introduire cette réforme sans avoir
mené la concertation nécessaire et peut
être prématuré et la profession s'en est
ému en commission il était reconnu comme
modifier le mécanisme de l'élection des
assesseurs assure une lecture était
peut-être pardonnez mon expression un
peu cavalier et c'est le premier point
ensuite la politisation de cette
élection pourrait perturber la bonne
administration de la justice dans les
tribunaux paritaires qui ne pose pas de
problème dans son organisation actuelle
l'appartenance syndicale n'est pas un
obstacle pour ses jets actuellement
côtés du président du tribunal
d'instance la rendre obligatoire et donc
superflu et rien ne garantit collection
sera plus attractive même dans un cadre
pluraliste donc afin de permettre le
temps de la réflexion nous proposons
comme les précédents orateurs de
supprimer les alinéas introduisant la
nouvelle procédure de désignation des
assesseurs c'est le sens de cet
amendement si monsieur le sénateur a mon
numéro 150 de monsieur le ministre
bien merci madame la présidente si vous
le permettez je
dir est à la fois ma position sur les
autres amendements et je défendrai
l'amendement du gouvernement
pour dire tout simplement que la
question est maintenant connue vous
savez que la procédure de désignation
des assesseurs des tribunaux paritaires
des baux ruraux a montré d'un certain
point de vue son inefficacité
puisqu'à la fois elle a abouti à ce que
en 2010 elle n'a pas permis la
constitution de 18 des tribunaux
encaissé deuxièmement elle a un coût et
vit dans une préoccupation un coût
financier posiez la question monsieur le
sénateur
d'après ce que je crois savoir elle est
aux alentours de 4 à 5 millions d'euros
ce qui n'est pas négligeable dans la
situation où nous sommes et donc il y a
eu cette prise un amendement
gouvernemental qui a été débattue à
l'assemblée nationale et aujourd'hui
nous pouvons présenter un nouvel
amendement qui nous le pensons a tenu
compte à la fois des débats qui ont eu
lieu aussi bien au sénat qu'à
l'assemblée et qui ont été discuté aussi
avec les organisations professionnelles
et nous pouvons penser que aujourd'hui
la proposition que nous faisons a le
soutien des organisations
professionnelles
alors cet amendement il vise tout
simplement à préciser le mode de
désignation de ces tribunaux paritaires
en précisant plus clairement les
modalités de propositions des
représentants des preneurs par les
opéras représentative et des bailleurs
par les opéras aussi représentative mais
aussi la fédération départementale des
propriétaires privés ruraux il indique
également que c'est le premier président
de la cour d'appel qui procède à la
nomination des assesseurs après avis du
président voilà nous pensons que ces
modifications sont de nature à
privilégier les candidats les plus
compétents tout en tenant compte des
remarques je les dis de ce qui s'est
passé à
l'assemblée
en prenant aussi en compte les remarques
des op à disposer actuellement du plus
grand nombre d'assesseurs et je crois
que nous sommes arrivés à un compromis
d'efficacité de transparence de
représentativité et qu'il serait bon que
le travail qui est fait aujourd'hui par
le gouvernement soient reconnus sur
l'ensemble des bancs du sénat
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
demander l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur sur cet
amendement et sur les trois identique à
madame la présidente je propose que
l'ensemble de ces bons reconnaissent
l'avancée du gouvernement et vote son
amendement même si évidemment nous
aurions cet amendement aurait pu ne pas
être présenté à l'assemblée nationale en
deuxième lecture mais enfin il l'est
monsieur bailly donc il l'est il avance
et là c'est le mouvement le gouvernement
souhaitait avancer sur la désignation
des pour les tribunaux donc moi je suis
favorable à l'amendement du gouvernement
défavorable aux autres une telle
solution ça existe déjà
dans les tribunaux des affaires de la
sécurité sociale et ça marche c'est de
l'efficacité c'est du gain d'argent
tout le monde s'y retrouve donc j'ai mis
à nager mais un avis défavorable pour ou
retrait pour les trois amendements et un
avis favorable pour celui du du
gouvernement qui encadre qui permet un
peu mieux de d'améliorer les choses oui
monsieur le rapporteur donc
monsieur le ministre a donné son avis
sur ces trois amendements je vais doctor
donner la parole à monsieur deneux
huit mois je ne partage pas du tout
l'avis du gouvernement je ne comprends
pas que ce soit une avancée c'est un
recul quand on passe d'un système où on
vote qui implique des conditions
démocratiques qu on fonctionnait depuis
70 ans et qu'on vit maintenant on va y
est désigné c'est une avancée c'est tout
de même assez incompréhensible et je
voudrais vous dire monsieur milices que
c'est pas parce que dans dix huit
endroits si on les analyse un par un ce
sont les endroits où que ce ferme âge
est peu répandu pour des raisons locales
dans tous les départements où faire marc
est important voire dominant les
tribunaux paritaires donne totalement
satisfaction il est incompréhensible que
cette affaire vienne par ce gouvernement
aujourd'hui nous serons forcément compte
les avis de ce gouvernement
merci monsieur bailly
madame la présidente explications de
vote
j'ai bien entendu les réponses mg le
ministre et c'est vrai que je les dis
d'un peu de moins d'intervention tout à
l'heure j'ai des interrogations
c'est un petit peu dommage qu'on n'en
parle pas plus longtemps mais j'aurai
une question précise on parle des
organisations syndicales donc ça veut
dire que les chambres d'agriculture dont
il ya des élections là vraiment de tous
les agriculteurs les propriétaires quand
il y avait des renouvellements des
chambres d'agriculture tout le monde et
puis je crois que le taux de
participation est encore plus important
que dans toutes les chambres consulaires
et dans beaucoup de gagnants
professionnel et je dois savoir la
raison pour qu'on a retenu plus les
organisations syndicales que les
chambres d'agriculture qui sont
représentatives et qui représentent
l'ensemble pour faire les propositions
justement de ses juges c'était ma
question ensuite bien sûr il y aura le
vôtre tel que vous l'avez souhaité merci
monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
président guillaume vous m'avez demandé
la parole
six ans marcel deneux il s'agit pas de
supprimer des tribunaux elles sont pas
supprimées continueront ils continueront
à exister il s'agit de moderniser
d'affaires vous avez combien de
participation à ces élections
vous savez comme et d'abstention dans
ces élections 80% d'abstention donc
s'agit d'être un peu plus efficace il
s'agit de faire en sorte on aurait pu ne
pas l'aborder d'adam dans ce texte mais
je pense que l'amendement du
gouvernement permet d'aller de l'avant
permet d'innover permet un peu de
moderniser c'est pas à bouger pour
bouger mais moi je pense pas que ça pose
de deux problèmes des problèmes
particuliers c'est aujourd'hui c'est
comme ça la sécurité sociale qui pensent
que ça ne fonctionne pas pour les
tribunaux de la sécurité sociale et
quels problèmes cela pose sans pause pas
devra peut-être pas perdre passer un
quart d'heure sur un entonnoir mais je
pense que nous pouvons passer au vote
merci monsieur le rapporteur
donc je mets au vote d'abord les trois
amendements 22 62 46 ans 44 qui ont reçu
deux avis défavorables
qui est pour
et qui est contre
ces trois amendements ne sont pas
adoptées amendement numéro 152 du
gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient cet amendement est adopté
je mets aux voix l'article 4 de ce
projet de loi qui est pour
et qui est contre
cet article iv est adopté
je mets au voir l'article 4 bis aa
je vais commencer par vous faire voter
qui est pour et qui est contre
donc il est adopté article 4 bis ab même
vote
article canalis à ces mêmes votes
alors l'article 4 bis à a été supprimé
il le demeure
article 4 bis même vote
nous en arrivons à l'article 4 ter à
avec un amendement numéro 28 présenté
par madame ferrat merci mais le
président madame la présidente je veux
propose de rétablir cet article dans la
rédaction issue de nos débats de
première lecture l'assemblée nationale
l'a malheureusement supprimer le droit
du métayer d'obtenir automatiquement la
conversion du métayage en fermage sous
la seule condition d'une antériorité de
8 ans est de nature à dissuader les
propriétaires de conclure un bail à
métayage il compromet la sécurité
juridique des montages de portage
foncier fondé sur l'économie du bail à
métayage ce droit est rarement mise en
oeuvre au bénéfice des exploitants
ils constituent une menace permanente
pour les propriétaires et joue en
définitive le plus souvent à l'encontre
des exploitants en dissuadant les
investisseurs et en orientant les
propriétaires vers des solutions
alternatives au bail telles que
l'exploitation en prestation de service
c'est pourquoi cet amendement de
proposer supprime simplement ce droit de
conversion automatique
et un madame la sénatrice avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
la présidente s'agit de la suppression
de la conversion de plein droit du bail
à métayage à bail à ferme l'article 4
117 ans du code rural madame et de la
pêche maritime permet de convertir tout
bail à métayage en bail à ferme à
l'expiration de chaque année culture à
la portée de la troisième année du bail
initial
cette conversion intervient soit au
choix du preneur soit au choix du
bailleur elle ne peut pas être refusée
lorsque le métayer la demande après huit
années l'amendement propose de supprimer
cette conversion de plein droit sur
demande du métayer à échéance du 8
années cet amendement avait été adopté
par le sénat en première lecture il ne
concerne que la viticulture que la
viticulture or si l'on peut comprendre
que le propriétaire soit mécontent de la
situation d'incertitude que cela crée la
modification de la loi sur ce point
contribuerait à modifier les équilibres
économiques de nombreuses régions
viticoles ou le bail à métayage est
encore utilisé et il l'est dans beaucoup
d'endroits l'adoption par le sénat de
cet article a d'ailleurs fait l'objet de
quelques contestations si dans un
langage fleuri ce qui montre qu'il n'y a
pas de consensus sur le sujet c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'aime et un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur à vis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie mais la présidente
à l'évidence
la france est riche de terroir divers et
finalement ce que nous avons vécu dans
la discussion sur la carte des régions
nous le voyons aussi peut-être à travers
cet amendement il n'ya pas c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire unanimité madame
le sénateur dans
l'idée que vous avez avancé donc nous
préférons évidemment qu'elle ne soit pas
reprise merci monsieur le ministre mal à
me faire à oui merci madame la
présidente c'est vrai et vous l'avez dit
monsieur le rapporteur cela touche
essentiellement la viticulture et
particulièrement la viticulture
champenoise nous sommes en ce moment
sous cette complexité ou certains
propriétaires n'ayant plus les moyens de
faire exploiter se voir récupérer entre
guillemets par des jeux ne sait comment
dire des exploitations où des des
maisons de champagne de grande
importance qui assurant des prestations
de services avec une facilité
déconcertante
voit échapper sans doute à de plus
jeunes exploitants la possibilité de
mettre en oeuvre
une entreprise de qualité voilà c'était
le sens de cet amendement je comprends
que l'unanimité n'étant pas là pas même
une majorité je suis obligé de le
retirer mais je vous avoue que je le
retiens la mort dans l'âme je ne réponds
pas à un vrai besoin et à des
difficultés et à des des personnes qui
s'engouffrent dans cette brèche profite
je n'ai pas peur de le dire du système
merci madame la sénatrice donc cet
amendement numéro 28 est retiré et
l'article 4 à n'est pas rétabli nous
passons à l'article 4 pièces avec un
amendement 29 rectifié toujours madame
ferrat je ne m'adresse pas madame la
présidente
merci mes chers collègues il s'agit là
encore de rétablir un article que nous
avions adopté en première lecture aux
commissions et qu'ils n'avaient pas été
modifiées par notre assemblée c'est une
question d'harmonisation normative entre
le régime du bail cessible et celle du
bail rural d'usagé commun actuellement
renouvelé pour une période de cinq ans
il est proposé de le renouveler pour
neuf ans tel que le prévoit l'article l
411 50 du code rural
applicables au bail classique cet
amendement vise à plus de cohérence dans
le code rural si madame la sénatrice
pour la commission avis du rapporteur
de la commission donne un avis favorable
merci monsieur ministre ce geste un
poison
bien je mets donc cet amendement 29
rectifié aux voix il a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission et david
singer du gouvernement qui est pour
et qui est contre
belle unanimité donc cet amendement est
adopté et donc je mets au voile article
que donc l'article 4 5 s est rétabli
merci voilà article 5 qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est adopté article 6 même vote
article 7 je suis saisi d'un amendement
du rapporteur monsieur le président
guillaume au nom de la commission
l'ordination dans la pression merci à
vis du gouvernement
rome très bien je mets aux voix cet
article 165 cet amendement pardon même
si le président de la commission m'a pas
rappelée à l'ordre donc cet amendement
numéro 165 qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est adopté un amendement du mérou 35
défendu par monsieur le cam
la présidente ce mini chers collègues
oui en première lecture au sénat avait
adopté à l'article 7 du projet de loi un
alinéa visant à interdire les rabais
remises et ristournes pour les produits
alimentaires figurant sur une liste
établie par décret nous étions convenus
que ces pratiques commerciales présenter
les inconvénients majeurs pour les
producteurs qui était dans un rapport de
force extrêmement défavorable la
commission des affaires économiques de
l'assemblée nationale a supprimé cet
ajout c'est pourquoi nous vous le
présentons à nouveau en espérant qu'il
ait un sort aussi heureux qu'au sénat la
dernière fois
merci à vue de la commission c'est le
rapporteur
je donnerai un avis de jeu demande
l'avis du gouvernement pardon alors à
vis du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci mme la présidente
l'avis du gouvernement un circonstancié
mais il se conclut de façon défavorable
le sénat les dispositions de l'article
441 2 1 prévoit pour les produits
entrant dans son champ d'application des
relations contractuelles formalisé
différente du contrat elle émeut avec
convention unique pour ses produits la
formalisation de la relation commerciale
est réduite et ne concerne donc plus que
certaines dispositions telles que les
remises des rabais des ristournes la
modification proposée sur le sénateur et
en ses dispositions particulières qui
prévoit une formalisation des relations
simplifiée par rapport au contrat elle
aimait aujourd'hui applicables à une
liste limitée de produits agricoles de
produits de la pêche et de l'agriculture
a potentiellement tout produit
alimentaire
elle conduit de fait à modifier la
relation contractuelle sans aucune étude
d'impact préalable
elle a pour effet de limiter la
formalisation de l'encadrement des
engagements réciproques entre
fournisseurs et clients alors même que
cette formalisation et protectrice des
fournisseurs en effet elle assure une
certaine transparence des relations
entre fournisseurs distributeurs elle
permet de garantir un certain équilibre
des relations notamment ce qui concerne
les réductions de prix les modalités de
la coopération commerciale ainsi que les
autres obligations et donc il serait
illusoire de penser que compte tenu de
certaines difficultés rencontrées dans
l'application des contrats lme et vous
avez raison de ce point de vue il serait
plus protecteur d'avoir une
formalisation réduite que de la relation
commerciale donc nous sommes dans ces
conditions nous ne sommes pas prêts à
accepter cette prise de risque
supplémentaire qu'elles que soient
parfois les insatisfactions que l'on
peut avoir sur la situation actuelle
doux
l'aspect défavorable à votre moment un
succès date merci monsieur le ministre
je mets aux voix cet amendement numéro
35 qui a reçu un avis défavorable du
gouvernement mais c'est de ne vous avez
la parole
que je je comprends mal la position du
gouvernement par rapport à ce que nous
entendons en permanence dans des
déclarations philosophe verbale c'est
vrai il faut se maîtriser la relation
entre la grande distribution et
fournisseurs
il faut défendre les producteurs mais la
frilosité du gouvernement est telle
qu'on ne fait rien et que quand par
hasard il ya un essai d'avancé le
gouvernement recule il est clair que
dans cette affaire le gouvernement n'est
pas cohérent donc nous voterons compte
merci monsieur deneux jeu mais envoie
donc cet amendement numéro 35
qui est pour
alors qui est pour
et qui est contre
cet amendement est adopté
un amendement numéro 34
oui madame la présidente dans le droit
fil du précédent le célèbre coefficient
multiplicateur qui je le rappelle a été
votée ici au sénat ya quelques années
sous l'impulsion de notre ami daniel
soulage du lot et ancien sénateur du
lot-et-garonne alors nous avons
présentées en donc cet amendement en
première lecture nous sommes en effet
importants comme je les dis dans la
discussion générale de faire des
propositions afin de garantir aux
agriculteurs une juste rémunération de
leur travail il faut dans ce cas
d'assurer un juste prix toutes les idées
sont bonnes à prendre pour essayer de
rétablir une plus juste répartition de
la valeur ajoutée sur l'ensemble de la
chaîne de production et de
commercialisation agricole la réunion
qui a eu lieu hier a été très
instructive sur les différentes
possibilités envisagées ainsi serge
papin propose d'amender la lme en fixant
des niveaux de vente minimum au dessus
du seuil de revente à perte le
coefficient multiplicateur est une autre
des mesures possible en mai période de
crise conjoncturelle tel que défini à
l'article l 611 4 du code rural et de la
pêche maritime ou en prévision de la
survenue d'une telle crise les ministres
compétents peuvent décider de
l'application d'un coefficient
multiplicateur
entre le prix d'achat et le prix de
vente des fruits et légumes périssables
à un taux et pour une durée qu'ils
définissent celle ci ne pouvant excéder
trois mois les mêmes établissent la
liste précise des produits visés par
cette mesure par notamment devant nous
élargissons le champ d'application de
cette mesure aux produits agricoles
périssables
sachant que la mise en oeuvre du
dispositif restent entre les mains du
pouvoir réglementaire qui nous semble
que c'etait large issement est tout à
fait raisonnable
nous savons monsieur le rapporteur que
vous avez changé d'avis depuis 2010 sur
l'opportunité d'une telle mesure
cependant nous ne pensons pas que
l'argument tiré de l'absence de moyens
de contrôles administratifs des prix que
vous avez développé en première lecture
soit une raison à renoncer à une telle
mesure vous nous avez exprimé également
votre crainte de la tentation de
s'approvisionner hors de nos frontières
pour maintenir des prix bas pour le
consommateur vous avez raison ce risque
existe il s'accentuera pour d'autres
productions comme la viande avec le
traité de libre-échange 30
transatlantique donc nous considérons
pour d'autre part que le coefficient
multiplicateur reste une bonne mesure
nous vous demandons donc d'abord
d'adopter cet amendement tout en ne
fermant la porte à aucun progrès qui
puisse permettre des prix rémunérateurs
à l'ensemble du monde agricole
merci monsieur le sénateur avis de la
commission monsieur leur apportant
la présidente cher gérard le cam je ne
pense pas qu'il faille en rajouter je
donne un avis défavorable
ce débat est récurrent nous le portons
depuis des décennies je m'étais laissé
convaincre dans les années 90 du
bienfait du coefficient multiplicateur
et je les défends du temps que j'ai pu
et je me suis aperçu que malheureusement
ça ne fonctionnait pas donc par principe
de réalité j'ai un avis défavorable
si monsieur le rapporteur à vis du
gouvernement
on voit bien que le coefficient
multiplicateur peut jouer sur des
produits frais dans des conditions
particulières un rôle utile mais on voit
bien que si on voulait l'étendre il y
aurait un certain nombre de dangers en
dehors des dysfonctionnements déjà noté
par le rapporteur il y aurait les
dangers de substitution par des produits
importés
et donc ceci par rapport aux produits
français donc je pense que ce n'est pas
du tout le but recherché par monsieur le
sénateur donc je l'invite à retirer
peut-être cet amendement merci monsieur
le ministre monsieur le sénateur hoche
la tête les gars tivement donc je le
mets aux voix
je me revois cet amendement qui a reçu
deux avis défavorables de la commission
et du gouvernement l'amendement numéro
34 qui et pour
qui et contre cet amendement n'est pas
adoptée jamais aux voix l'article 7 qui
et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient cet article 7 est adopté
voilà vous avez donc pu suivre l'examen
du projet de loi sur l'agriculture
l'alimentation et la forêt un texte
adopté par les sénateurs le 24 juillet
dernier